lockdown isn't a strategy it's a
delaying action
the question is how much time will this
lock down by
us simplify this right down think of it
like a tug of war between two forces
social distancing and the growth of the
virus lockdown
powers up social distancing but we're
not doing it completely
and 50 000 people a day at catching the
virus in the uk
so the virus is still strong you can see
this in action
if you look at the first set of
lockdowns last time around
the uk delayed so growth was high when
we went in
france locked down earlier and with
stricter measures
so its lockdown was shorter ours was one
of the longest
in europe you can see this with scotland
wales northern ireland
maybe this time in england has delayed
will we see the same effect
we do actually have a scientific
assessment of the impact of lockdowns
not for a month but for the two-week
circuit breaker
suggested by sage in september they
analyzed what a two-week lockdown
over the october half term would do to
hospital admissions
the white line here is what would happen
with no intervention and
all these are different scenarios like
moderate strict
total and this of course total being
what we had back in april
two things are true of all these
scenarios first no matter what happens
it takes some time to have an effect
look hospitalizations keep on growing
even after lockdown has come in second
under all these scenarios hospitals and
admissions
bounce back really very quickly in the
strictest scenario this blue one total
lockdown
takes about six weeks in the second
strictest which is roughly comparable to
r1
takes about four weeks we're in lockdown
for longer so we'll get a longer grace
period
but eventually the virus will come
roaring back
that's why the question for the
government is how will we use this time
we've bought
and for all of us can we change our
behavior
to stop lockdowns three and even four